n quelle heure il est j'ai pas là qu'il
est mais je sais qu liste le marchand de
sable et gros souvienne c'est oui mais
oui mes chers petits amis ainsi que nous
vous l'avions promis nous voici de
retour
vous savez nous avons passé deux très
belles vacances vous a fait du camping
au bord de la mer est grosse bourse a
rapporté de très jolis étoiles pour
petits douillet mirabel des étoiles
d'humbert patron je t'ai sont vite les
apporter à mes deux petits amis hum hum
hop là oui oui mais mais mais dépêche
toi tu as compris bien sûr patron comme
d'habitude pom pom pom pom pom pom pom
[Musique]
bonjour mes enfants chéris oncle a
besoin d'elle
il y a des fleurs partout partout il y
en a même sur la cheminée et et ses
photos mais
elle est l'aînée mais je veux c'est moi
rappelle dale éminent bocaly louis et
vous me l'aviez déchiré petit garnement
et ça oui je sais je sais et un gros
tiff ce que tu est en voyage
attendez là et tenez les enfants ça
c'est pour vous non nous étions à la mer
et on a fait du camping sous une tente
et ulysse à pêcher pour vous ces belles
étoiles de mer j'ai pas pu
j'avais oublié mon bikini bien des
châteaux de sable sur la plage des
partis très proches il faut sur la tête
petit garnement parce que j'ai eu les
oreillons moi aussi peu mais je suis
guéri et j'ai encore les oreilles un peu
sensibles tel un gros papillon comme
bons ballons les enfants au lit
[Musique]
moi aussi et émerger une liste noire
mais vite mes petits-enfants à deux
bords demain on montrera comment notre
appel et vopillon ou non attrapé
beaucoup à la campagne et la jettent à
la lumière au revoir les enfants à
demain
[Musique]
oh
sonné petit louis bony petite mirabelle
bonne nuit tous mes chers petits amis
embrasser bien vos parents allaient vite
au dodo et en dormez vous bien sagement
nous reviendrons vous voir sans faute de
main bonne nuit à demain 1 2 voilà
nounours allons en route
bonne nuit l'onu l'ue
[Musique]
oh